what are you learning then so far in the
podcast that's what is informing you
because you're talking to these amazing
women what are they are they teaching
you stuff that's inspiring you are they
telling you stuff that's making you
think okay first of all I think it'd be
great when you talk to a Jane fond and
she's 85 or a cal Burnett and she's 90.
the fact that they're still here and
still interested
and that's inspiring in and of itself
yeah well you know Jane Fonda
particularly she talks about uh
uh the different acts of life of the
first the second and the third act she's
she's in her own mind she's sort of
broken down the aging process into three
acts and so now she's in her third act
and
um and she's done she's done what she
calls A Life review and and in which she
really went back over her life and tried
to understand where it is she has been
right
um which is an interesting thing to
consider personally you know and I'm in
my third act right and I'm starting to
think about wow it was it was mind
expanding to me talking to her and so
many other people Ruth Reichel for
example uh the the former editor of
gourmet magazine in the New York Times
food critic and she also she's like 75 I
think and she was talking about
you the how important it is to keep
doing things that frighten you
and
which is an interesting thing to
consider
um and and basic things like really
honestly staying physically fit if
because it will inform this uh she
didn't say this this is very much Jane
and also Isabel Allende staying
physically fit and healthy is hugely
meaningful as you get older I mean it's
so obvious but then when you really
start to consider it I think to a
certain extent uh you don't think about
getting I mean you do think about
getting older but it creeps up on you I
mean how old are you do you mind my
asking not at all uh and this is a
frequent topic of discussion much of the
Delight of my compatriots here yes
um this drop on April 17th on April 18th
I turn 60. and so everything you're
talking about is stuff I've been
thinking about because there was so much
in my career where I was the youngest
guy in the room tell me about it and and
people would say
um I was in college like the young guy
that ran the magazine the comedy
magazine then you know I when I got a
late night show uh I was I just turned
30. so you're this young whippers like
way too young you know people were like
what's no and um and green and then
there was just years and years and years
where well there's the hosts at 11 30
and then there's the that kooky rooster
guy over there in late night and then
what happens is
suddenly it it felt to me like it
suddenly flipped to give us your wisdom
old man I'm like what are you talking
about but it happens it does happen and
now I interview a lot of younger people
in comedy and like well I grew up I know
watching you I was in diapers as you
were
hitting 50 and I'm like Jesus Christ
what happened but I'm I keep coming back
to the same general feeling of of
gratitude and just happy to be here but
I will tell you I've been doing a lot of
inventorying I do I've been thinking of
it in 20-year Cycles like okay one to
twenty you know age one to twenty got me
to this point in my life yeah age 20 to
40 got me to this other part and then 40
to 60 got me here and so that's how I'm
coming to thinking about it it's got me
keeping score adding it up and for the
most part feeling content about which is
fantastic because I mean what else is
the point and and are you are you are
you pivoting in any way like as you move
into this next sort of
what do you want to call it your next 20
years I call it my dotage into your
dotage no but for real like are you
making adjustments are you thinking
about it like that in any way yeah no it
to be I mean there's all these jokes
that come to mind and I think no just
yeah just tell just tell
um but first the jokes yeah yeah I'm
getting a lot of work done Shane yeah
I'm getting an eye job no uh the the
um the reality of it is I
love I mean we started talking about
this and I we addressed it already but
how this technology has changed
and there's a way now that I can be
practice my craft whatever you want to
call it not being high flute and
try and get my personality across which
is in essence all I've been trying to do
since I was a kid
and then when I got into broadcasting
it's just trying to do that on a bigger
scale but this podcast has been a real
Revelation to me that I can
you know you came on The Late Night show
several times and we had some really
great moments and you did some you did
some great stuff one of my favorites is
uh when uh Tina Fey came on oh that was
fun you wanted to steal Tina's Emmy and
you knew Tina was uh upstairs at
Saturday Night Live in the building
that's right and I and joined you to
come with me and we were gonna go steal
it ran up a Stairway we went up a
stairwell it was so much fun that bit
came out well yes and we did it live we
did it live
stole her Emmy came back down and
there's a great moment where we Contin
we go on with things and then she shows
up in the doorway yeah and so I guess
the the point I was making is there were
things that you could do
um comedy bits and we could have a short
conversation
and I I loved that I mean I I adored
that and I'm glad that I got to do it
um but now
the fact that there's a way that I can
talk to you
in this way in this manner in a more
sort of genuine yeah genuine and it's
feels different to me and to me the
whole key is just keep trying new things
and um that's the thing keep trying
don't just keep as much as there are
people that would say oh my God I just
wish Seinfeld had kept going no Seinfeld
needed to stop you know right and and
then you needed uh to do sitcoms and
then you needed to do yeah single camera
and then you needed to you know you just
like you you need to do movie work and
then you have to do you have to keep
trying things that you are
challenged by and they're not in your
muscle memory so to me that's the thing
is I just want to
um keep putting myself out there in
different ways and and then be honest
about it if something doesn't work it
didn't work yeah well I mean something
will eventually not work but that's okay
I'm just uh no no everything you do is
perfect well that's the sub text yes yes
pardon me yes of course I'm stating the
obvious but
um never a stumble the Conan O'Brien
story but I think but that is actually
never a stumble
um
but yeah I think that trying new things
keeping it uh sort of fresh that way is
is I think an uh well first of all it's
a great way to live life and also I
think it's a great way to uh to have
longevity